- When are we getting
a new single from you?
- Oh, we're getting something
new with the premiere.
I tried not to cut the legs off
of the theme song that
I did for Raising Kanan,
so I didn't release it.
- But BMF, the theme song for BMF is me,
Moneybagg Yo and Snoop Dog.
They'll hear that.
- What?
- That'll be out on the 23rd.
(audience applauding)
- Oh my god, I love it.
(audience excitedly yelling)
I just got to, I worked with Snoop Dog,
a season ago on The Voice.
Oh my god, it was the greatest thing ever
because he was so high.
(chuckling)
- He's funny.
- But it was like, he's
sitting in the chair,
but it was like, it
was like, is he asleep?
Like, and then he, and then he'd wake up
thinking he he was so into.
- Yeah, because even when he's like,
he's high he's, he's just not, he's high.
- He's in the zone.
- He's like this, he'd still hear you.
- I know. It's literally like...
(laughter)
(audience clapping)
- Like it's still going on.
He's like yo, you think 'cause he's high,
he can't hear you,
but he'd been high for like 10 years.
(laughter)
- Like longer.
- I tried to tell him he couldn't smoke
when I was, cause I directed him.
He is in...
- Oh my god.
- He is in BMF also.
And when I was directing him
and I was like, "Yo, you can't,
you can't do that on set."
He was like,
"what is you talking
about nephew? It's legal.
(laughter)
- What are you talking about?
This is, has nothing to do.
I was trying to use COVID.
I was like,
"No, the COVID, the COVID."
- You're trying to disguise it
with something else, yeah.
- It's legal.
- I love that you were trying to get
Snoop Dog, like,
that's like trying to get Willie Nelson
not to smoke on tour or something.
(laughter)
- It's not gonna happen.